is it shallow of me to not want to date
a guy who has a pit wouldn't do it not
worth the risk anytime you have a pet
anytime you have a dog in there any kind
of dog there's always a Chance the dog
could bite the chance is much too high
that this dog will attack the child and
then the other problem too it's not just
about will the dog bite the child if the
dog snaps or gets angry or whatever like
if a golden retriever bites you it'll
hurt be painful maybe you need snitches
but you don't very often hear about
Golden Retrievers mauling people to
death that's a pimples if they decide to
attack you they will try to kill you so
you're sort of like trusting this dog to
not do that and uh that's not trust I
would have and I do think it's a valid
concern I don't I don't think it's silly
at all if this works out and I marry
this man I want to have kids I'm not
gonna have kids with a pit bull now I'm
just not going to I only have to you
have to toss this guy to the side right
away but it is something to bring up you
say I think this is I think this is
really going in a great Direction I you
know I really like you all these kind of
things talking about but but then also
say I don't want to be around the pit
bull I can't imagine ever raising kids
around a pitbull and let them let them
decide what's the most important